unser ziel ist es nach wie vor
neuinfektionen so gut wie möglich und
mit aller kraft meine damen und herren
zu verhindern und wir müssen verhindern
dass menschen überhaupt erst krank
werden und nur so lässt sich verhindern
dass kontakte in quarantäne müssen dass
das virus zu risikogruppen
weitergetragen wird dass patienten ins
krankenhaus oder sogar auf die
intensivstation kommen dass menschen
sterben und dass menschen langzeitfolgen
durch ko wird 19 erleiden wir stehen
diesem virus nicht machtlos gegenüber
wir haben eine gute strategie
sie besteht seit anfang an aus drei
teilen eindämmung schutz abbildung was
bedeuten diese drei pfeiler im einzelnen
erstens eindämmung der krankheit zur
eindämmung können und müssen wir aber
auch wirklich alle beitragen beherzigen
wir doch alle die asl regeln halten wir
abstand wo immer möglich halten wir die
hygieneregeln ein tragen wir dort wo
immer möglich alltags masken oder
medizinische mund nasen schutz und
lüften wir meine damen und herren
und zwar immer und überall auch in
alltagssituationen ob das nun im
privaten oder im beruflichen bereich wo
immer das möglich ist bitte tun wir das
alle konzentrieren wir unsere kontakte
wirklich auf ein minimum treffen wir uns
generell mit zu wenig menschen wie
möglich
das virus verbreitet sich dort wo
menschen zusammenkommen
gerade wenn man sich gut kennt und näher
zusammenrückt natürlich verzichten sie
auf solche treffen bitte schützen sie
sich und ihre familien und ihre freunde
wir alle schützen bitte unsere familien
und unsere freunde und wenn sie symptome
einer akuten atemwegsinfektionen haben
bleiben wir bitte alle fünf tage zu
hause damit wir niemanden anstecken und
natürlich bleibt die arbeit der
gesundheitsämter weiter zentrale
infektionsketten aufspüren und
aufbrechen und dadurch unterbrechen das
zweite element dieser strategie ist der
schutz für besonders gefährdete gruppen
zum beispiel für menschen altenheim die
ein hohes risiko haben an kopf mit 19 zu
erkranken und zwar schwer zu erkranken
hier ist es ganz entscheidend dass das
virus eben erst gar nicht in die heime
hineingetragen wird auch dazu können wir
natürlich selber beitragen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich ganz
besonders den vielen pflegekräften
danken die selbst alles dafür tun um
einen eintrag in ihr heim auch zu
verhindern neben der arbeit die sie in
den heimen leisten sie arbeiten oft
unter schweren bedingungen fiel auch
weit weg von der eigenen familie und sie
alle leisten in der pandemie großartiges
bitte machen sie weiter so helfen sie
weiter dabei ihre bewohner zu schützen
und das dritte element der pandemie
bekämpfungsstrategie ist die milderung
also dass abmildern der folgen dieser
pandemie zb durch neue und bessere
therapieansätze oder durch aufstockung
von kapazitäten im krankenhaus und
natürlich auch meine damen und herren
durch eine impfung die in deutschland
bald verfügbar sein wird
und diese drei elemente eindämmung
schutz und bildung die müssen weiter
aufrecht erhalten werden und jeder von
uns kann an dem platz an dem das möglich
ist dazu beitragen dass diese strategie
erfolgreich bleibt nur gemeinsam wird es
uns gelingen das infektionsgeschehen auf
ein level zu bringen mit dem wir alle
umgehen können wir können die trendwende
nur gemeinsam schaffen strengen wir uns
also alle gemeinsam an
am sonntag ist der dritte advent das
jahr 2020 geht bald zu ende nicht aber
unsere solidarität
gemeinsam zeigen wir diesen virus die
stirn
danke sehr mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren